حفل مبهرج واستعراض وتبجج لبن مجرد فرصه
لالتقاط الصور اوصاف الصقت بزياره الرئيس
الصيني الى روسيا فصحيفه ذيلجراف
البريطانيه اكدت ان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين لم يحصل على الكثير من
زياره نظيره الصيني واضافت ان البيان
المشترك للرئيسين الصيني والروسيه يشير
الى ان القاده لم يحققوا اي اختراقات
كبيره خصوصا في الملف الاوكراني حيث لم
تتضمن الزياره التي دامت ثلاثه ايام اي
اعلان مفاجئ عن دعم عسكري من بكين لموسكو
وخلت طبعا من مناوره دبلوماسيه صينيه
مفاجئه بشان محادثات السلام وبقيت بخانه
الوسيط الحاسم مجاملات من الجانبين مملوءه
بنفس العبارات الماليه حول شراكه بلا حدود
وصداقه واهداف مشتركه وزياده الصفقات
التجاريه لتبقى الصفقات التجاريه الموقعه
العامل الوحيد المساعد لروسيا في مواجهه
الجفاف الاقتصادي المستمر في زمن الحرب
والعقوبات طبعا لكن ابرز ما كان واضحا
خلال اجتماعات الرئيسين الروسي والصيني هو
التاكيد على حقبه جديده وعالم متعدد
الاقطاب ووفقه مراقبين هنا رحله الرئيس
الصيني الى موسكو لعبت لصالح بلاده اكثر
من ملاعبت لصالح روسيا على الاقل علنا
فيما قيل خلف الابواب المغلقه فهو طبعا
غير معروف
[موسيقى]